v gates veegaete veegaete
ça marche pas messieurs dames nouveau
sauf réveil je sais la valeur fin on a
déjà fait un seul bris dit mais je me
suis super mal organisées cette semaine
sur planning des vidéos j'ai ce week-end
lors du g20 fait un truc incroyable club
house mais moi je suis content c'est la
première fois que je passe autant de
temps sur un truc manuel
je suis si heureux c'est les ss
international space station incroyable
ou pas les gars merci merci beaucoup
merci
j'aurais jamais confiance en moi j'aime
journée et applaudi quand je fais le
moindre petit truc
merci beaucoup oh merde je suivrai dit
aujourd'hui il s'appelle dit aïe
ouailles avec un petit jeu de mot genre
dit aïe pourquoi en gros seins se briser
sur lequel on retrouve les inventions et
les créations de tad humain c'est soit
des trucs qui crée pour décorer leur
appartement soit des trucs qui créent et
qui sont pratiques
on va regarder leur création puis on va
juger parce qu'on est devenus des
vétérans de l'activité manuelle alors on
peut se permettre
leçon c'était pas assez j'avais besoin
de ressentir les sensations de larmes
alors j'ai fabriqué ça
vous voyez excusez moi mais le bruit
c'est terrible il faut pas être son
voisin j'hésite entre ces méga stylet et
c'est parfaitement inutile jeu sur un
entre deux en vrai c'est pas mal mais
moi je préfère le côté performance genre
d'une souris simple tu vois un mur piano
jeu étrange je comprends l'idée mais
d'un autre côté je me of awesome thiou
cerveau empêche tout ça charmant les
vieux objets là il a un vieux piano
classique et tout bas autant le mettre
en entier vu que c'est un vieux père le
piano classique et si tu veux juste
matin que la vie qui dépasse du mur tu
achètes un comme ça lors électronique
une canne là on est sur un entre-deux
bizarre dans sam temps il tend son piano
qui veut ça
chez lui voilà les tutos comme sale et
laid fac ça me tue avec des bouteilles
d'eau
qu'est-ce qui fabrique à c'est tout un
sac de linge sale pourquoi pas celle pas
de réponse on tiendra compte quoi
non mais les gars il faut arrêter avec
vos piano là je suis désolé je m'emporte
et son super beau mais juste poser les
et c'est réglé
il n'y a pas besoin de le faire
traverser un mur ou de le mettre au
dessus d'une plaque de cuisson sa bande
ont fusé impressionnant le gao
ce miroir mousse
[Musique]
ok donc ils ont mis de la mousse elle
s'est solidifiée et au jeu j'aime pas du
tout on dirait des intestin grêle
je sais qu on a le droit de pas avoir le
même avis mais pour moi ça me fait
penser à des artistes alors que je
m'attendais à ce que ça fasse genre des
petits nuages tout autour tu vois je
désolé mais le petit filtre shiny me ne
rattrape pas les intestins galles
regardez moi ce dialogue facile
qu'est ce qu'il a fait
[Musique]
j'adore je conçois que plein de gens
n'aiment pas et j'accepte votre jugement
en ce moment même mais comme objets de
décoration c'est j'adore j'ai fait un
ustensile pour exposer les bulles du
papier bulle ça devrait en vendre
partout attendez excusez moi mais il ya
un petit détail c'est qu'il il a pas
juste fabriquer l'objet
il en a fait une ceinture il est
déterminé à péter un max de papier bulle
le nombre de fois j'ai reçue du papier
bulle et où j'aurais rêvé d'avoir ce
truc là [ __ ] mais bien joué et frérot
mais pourquoi
[Musique]
et les gars c'est génial on est d'accord
c'est la version adulte de la bouteille
d'eau que tu coin cela dans ton vélo
équitable sur ta roue pour faire un
bruit de moto qui a fait ça le met là
bas abo du coup maintenant que tu as un
vrai moteur sur ton véhicule tu as
besoin de sonner comme un moteur plus
puissant faire très peur à tes voisins
en pilotant ce truc à 3 heures du matin
dans ta rue la tête et motorisé nathan
il va super bien les gars excusez moi
mais c'est génial c'est aussi j'en
commande de je découvre un délire de
foule à ya des gens qui adorent
fabriquer des trucs juste destinée à
faire peur entre la tête de bébé sache
au paradis là dans cette vidéo
j'avais un jour off à cause du coc vide
et j'ai fait ça pour ma femme
quel soldat quel soldat mais [ __ ] ça
les gars c'est du cabl management c'est
l'art de ranger soigneusement tous ces
câbles les gars y'a des tas de photos
sur internet de kemble management
soigner de fou je trouve ça hyper dur à
faire parce que l'image duo regardez
comme elle est décourageante tu as la
flemme de ranger ses câbles trouve ça
tellement of legal bennage mais je vous
jure je pourrais m'abonner 1 à only fans
de cables management les plaisirs d'un
pistolet à colle est piste la colle moi
j'avais adoré à terme elle je suis sûre
elle exploite pleinement le potentiel du
pistolet à colle
j'ai peur qu'est ce qui va se passer
n'est ce pas de la com qu'est-ce que
c'est
la chute avait encore tout ça pour se
gratter mais achète la tige là comme
tout le monde tu peut même le faire à
ton chien n'y a pas besoin de [ __ ] le
mur de sa touche à vous voyez ce moment
vous êtes chez des amis quelqu'un a
ramené une bouteille de vin mais ya pas
de tire bouchon pour le web généralement
les gens et c'est alors la technique de
la chaussure où tu mets la bouteille
dans une chaussure tu la frappe contre
un mur je sais pas quoi moi ça n'a
jamais marché
j'ai essayé deux fois les deux fois on a
pété la bouteille dans cette vidéo
quelqu'un nous donne la vraie solution
de ce problème
frire aux urnes à pâtir bouchon je suis
pas sûr qu'on ait une perceuse vraiment
énigmes et à faire à passer c'est de
pire en pire [ __ ] moi qui croyais que
c'était la vraie solution
je suis à deux doigts de commande et
tout ce qu'il faut pour essayer je vous
le dis j'ai fait une bague intéressantes
depuis un vieil article de national
geographic pour moi ça ça va dans la
catégorie de fabriquer des trucs qui
font peur là avec la veilleuse bébé et
le véhicule badens je vois l'idée mais
ça me ferait peur de voir un morceau de
visage au doigt de quelqu'un fût obligé
et honnête à l'idée se répand à travers
le monde tous les détenteurs d'une
poupée ont décidé d'en faire une
veilleuse horrifique
je trouve ça génial je sais ce que vous
pensez de moins ce moment on m'a dit moi
je suis pas le seul s'il vous plaît j'ai
fait un médiator hors amm
oh mais attendez monsieur vous êtes un
gros gamers ou quoi très bonne idée
j'adore mon robot pour me coiffer il ya
du mal ce rebond
les gars je suis pris dans bâti pour ce
robot s'il vous plaît faites lui plaisir
proposez lui de vous coiffer envoyons un
peu d'amour à ce robot il en a besoin
qu'est ce que c'est encore
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est moi quand j'entreprends
un truc manuel une boule à une boule de
cheveux de 125 kg faites par un coiffeur
mais ne rigole pas toi c'était pas drôle
ça ne coûte [ __ ] alors on devrait y a
rien de mal dans si c'était grâce merde
une autre venus ou pas la veilleuse la
veilleuse
[Musique]
mais c'est super comment tu bien dans ta
poche il devient épais comme ça ton
téléphone mais on dirait un bébé qui a
été en cimenté est restée en veilleuse
dégâts mais attends mais ya que des
dingueries les gars à levier de vitesse
mais xam rend triste faut vraiment être
en manque d'affection je suis ça me rend
triste genre ça se trouve il ya
l'histoire trouble au derrière ça
genre c'est un vrai moulage de la main
de sa femme décédée je change y être
autres glauque la voyez la vie aux bébés
c'était pas le look du tout j'installe
une chatière lol je me déteste
oh non pas comme ça mélanie pas comme ça
non c'est tellement moi si j'avais dû
installer une chatière au pourquoi
j'aime autant les trucs creepy j'ai un
vrai souci je les trouvais chez un
antiquaire mois les téléphones qui ce
slide et vous souvenez 7 et blackberry
les boss de ça à l'époque téléphone à
clapet mon tout premier ce terrain
clapper oyez ressemble au sony ericsson
à l'époque où ceux qui se souviennent
jeu l'odeur offrait le bois ou une
sympathique haïti molle nul à chier un
porte savon fait à partir de vieilles
pièces mise à part cette afro design
mais quel leader bordel quand le savons
il est mouillé que tu leur pose y glisse
l'un des pièces il remplit même pas sa
fonction au plus être moche ce truc si
je suis désolé si vous avez suivi le
tuto ya forcément dix personnes parmi
vous statistiquement c'est sûr qu'ils
l'ont fabriqué je comprends votre
douleur arrêt avait rien
l'erreur de la chattière je sais que
c'est une erreur que mas gens ont déjà
fait ça doit aller tellement vite
mais quoi mais qu'est ce qui leur prend
[Musique]
qu'elle aurait abordé
si je vois ça chez vous il ya moyen que
je tape dedans je suis désolé les gars à
lui demain dans une autre gracieux je
sais pas peut-être mais un bon gros pied
du 41 comme ça dans ta main je trouve
pas ça beau impossible à la fait j'aime
bien ça fait un peu jardin japonais ça y
est j'ai trouvé le truc que j'aime bien
une personne va aimer j'aime et bien
messieurs dames c'est la fin de notre
petit séjour sur le seul vrai didier
ouailles j'adore cette mode qui consiste
à inciter les gens à fabriquer des trucs
chez eux avec ce qu'ils ont chez eux je
trouve ça super cool mais ça donne lieu
quand même à des sacré truc à chiens
faut le dire mais quand même il ya des
petites bonnes idées à droite à gauche
qui font plaisir à voir sa santé lui
dois je lui mit rapidement ce que je
sais que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
reposez vous bien j'ai entendu dire que
c'était les vacances je vous dis à très
vite et amis portez vous bien c'est une
fin de vie des autres est formel
d'accord
[Musique]
et